It's been a tough year
for stocks and bonds around the world,
but there's one investment
that really stands out.
Private golf club
memberships in Singapore.
Values for memberships
at clubs like Sentosa
That means for locals,
they've got to pay the equivalent of about
For expats like me, it's more like
There's a couple of
reasons behind the surge.
There's just been a general increase
in interest in golf during the pandemic.
But more importantly,
there's been a surge
of wealthy foreigners coming to Singapore.
The long lockdown in China
made a lot of people want
to come to Singapore.
They really love our
lifestyle, our freedom.
I think most of them are here
doing some business.
We are quite happy that
they are coming and investing here.
They buy membership,
and they're putting a lot
of money in golf lessons,
which is very good for the game.